welcome to the heavy spoiler show
i'm your host definition and this video
we're breaking down 100 insane details
in the new batman trailer
i'll say right up top this is one of the
best videos i've ever made
and we've compiled a massive massive
list of all the details
references to other films and easter
eggs to break down everything you might
have missed
there may be some spoilers here as we
will be talking about some of the leaks
so if you want to go in as blind as a
bat then i highly recommend that you
turn off now
this is nothing plot ruining but it may
spoil some of the surprises in the film
which i definitely don't want to do if
you're still here huge thank you for
clicking the video
now let's get into the breakdown okay so
the trailer opens with the song
something in the way by nirvana
typically in tv shows and films
songs are chosen for the importance of
their lyrics which reflect what's going
on
the most recent example of this usage is
white is on the moon which appeared in
lovecraft country episode 2 yesterday
however this is a common occurrence in
films the nirvana song 2 carries this
motif
and it has several lyrics which i think
reflect the mind state of batman and
what's happening
the song was written by kurt cobain and
he details his time
living under a bridge as a loner in the
film batman is of course a loner
and at one point we can see that the bat
cave is actually located under a bridge
at an abandoned train station
which we'll talk about in just a bit now
the song also contains the lyrics the
animals i've trapped
have become my pets batman's rogues
gallery is made up of a vast number of
animal themed villains
from the penguin to kill a croc firefly
and many many more the character takes
them to arkham asylum which is where
they become trapped
and batman often visits them like
animals in a zoo
and though the link between the two is
slightly tenuous
the song clearly has a number of
metaphors and similarities that can be
applied
from here we cut to the riddler taping
up his first victim
the character's design is clearly based
upon elements of the zodiac killer
he wears a mask that's been put in place
to obscure his face
and glasses over the top the make and
model of these was actually found by
twitter account the bat source
and it is possible that the riddler has
bad eyesight which is why he needs to
done the spectacles
under the mask we can also see that he's
clearly wearing a forensic suit as well
i have a theory that the film might
actually need this not only to stop any
dna spreading to the crime
scene but that he may also be using it
as a disguise to hide amongst the police
at one point in the trailer we see
several people in forensic suits at the
crime scene
and though none of these are paul dano
the riddler may be using the suit as a
way to keep taps on the police
how chilling would it be if he was
actually there this whole time in the
scene
hiding amongst those brought in to
investigate the crime
yikes now there are a lot of theories
floating around saying that the riddler
is actually an amalgamation of the
villain hush
and well the riddler this was a plot
point in the animated film adaptation of
the graphic novel
and though it wasn't present in the
original source material
it could be a possibility in that bruce
was taunted by a villain that tied back
to his past called tommy elliott
growing up he was close friends with the
character and though they shared a lot
of similarities
tommy ended up going a different way
becoming the villain hush
now in my eyes it could be possible that
the riddler is a childhood friend of
bruce
that knows a lot about his past remember
that in the comics the riddler actually
figures out who batman
is and it could be that he's been so
close to the character that he's able to
see through the facade that he puts on
as bruce wayne
joining the dots over his identity this
is hinted at by the final line in the
trailer
in which the riddler tells batman that
he's a part of it too
now as for who the victim is this is
actually the mayor of gotham city
his death takes place in the character's
office which becomes a key location
later in the trailer
on the wall there are several newspaper
clippings for the character
and now they fly by in a split second
there are a number of things that we can
take from these
now firstly we can confirm that the
mayor's name is actually don mitchell jr
this can be seen in one of the headlines
which gives his first name as don
and then the second which gives the
title mayor mitchell jr
we can also see another headline
discussing how bellareal lost
bella real is played by jamie lawson and
on imdb
she's also listed as a mayoral candidate
with the mayor dead
this film could potentially open the
door to have the penguin run for the
position
and this is something that was present
in the 1966 show
the earth one graphic novel and batman
returns
it definitely could be in place here and
there are theories that the penguin has
a gang which is terrorizing the city
so that he can come in and seem like a
savior when he stops them
on another newspaper we can also see the
headline
seawall construction stalled in the dc
fandom panel
matt reeves stated that this film was
going to pull from movies like chinatown
which is actually based around the
california water wars
when we jump to the batcave later we can
see that it's actually part of a wayne
industry construction site
due to a sign that can be seen above the
archway this could perhaps be the sea
wall that the headline was referring to
as we already know that production was
stalled on it and it would explain why
the location looks so run down
there are also other things that we can
take from this and it was leaked last
year that batman will be using a bat
cave that is actually built into the
architecture of gotham city itself
and this seems to set this up it
actually looks like it might be an
abandoned train station
and this would give the character access
to several areas in gotham at once
it would allow him to travel underground
without being noticed i would also mean
that he could pop up and disappear
without drawing any attention to himself
we can also see in the cave that there's
the bat bike which was shown
in scenes and and had had the guy
falling
off it off his bike i'm sorry i'm sorry
i shouldn't have brought that up now you
may also notice that the bike scene that
we saw being filmed at a cemetery is
present in this trailer too
the fact that we see bruce riding in
without his costume
and we know that the batsuit appears
here later gives it away that the
cemetery will actually be the entrance
to the bat cave
and that the character will pop up here
time and time again
now jumping back from this tangent and
going to where we were at the beginning
are cut after the newspaper headlines
shows us the mayor with tape over his
face
and the text no more lies the character
is sat in the chair that was actually
shown in matt reeves photo of the
clapper board
which he posted on the first day of
filming we then hear the breathing of
the riddler over the top of this clip
and though this is meant to show that
the riddler is actually at this location
we can see in the scene that it's taking
part during the police investigation
due to the officer behind the body
wearing a white shirt and black tie
in the next shot we see gordon walking
towards the crime scene
now the fact that these are fbi officers
does add weight to this being the mayor
as it's unlikely that they'd be brought
in to just investigate any random murder
now these officers are actually looking
directly at the camera
and in hindsight we know that this is
batman this is actually a reference to
the silence of the lambs
in which a similar shot is used when
clarice stalling enters
a crime scene in that she was given
funny eyes by the officers
because she was a woman but batman is
clearly given funny eyes here because
well he's a man dressed as a bat now
both characters provided valuable
insight to the case
but i think the silence of the lamb's
references go far beyond that
the next shot we cut to the mayor with a
paper bag over his hand
and i believe that this is signifying
something very important
now the tape over his head is complete
overkill and it has clearly been done
for a reason
when one lies they're capable of doing
so through either speech
or by writing something his mouth being
taped up
symbolically will stop the mare from
lying through his teeth and the hand
having a bag over it to me
at least symbolizes that he will no
longer be able to write any lies either
and the fact that he's dead i also
believe that the silence of the lamb's
references
could go far beyond that in the film we
discover that the victims have moth
cocoons stuffed down their throats
and this got me thinking what if the
reason that the riddler taped up the
victim
is because they have something in their
mouth the film is also said to be
pulling from the long halloween
significantly
and in that graphic novel the calendar
man appears almost like a hannibal
lecter type villain
he provides valuable information on the
case much like how hannah elected it
and it is even possible that the
calendar man could be appearing in this
film
and that the references to the silence
of the lambs are here because of that
reason
from here we cut to james gordon and i
have to say that i think
jeffrey wright looks absolutely perfect
in the role we hear the line
from your secret friend and then who
now though i have seen some people say
that this is just the character
saying these lines out loud we actually
see that they're taken from
what's written on the front of riddler's
clue here you can clearly see the words
from your secret friend and then who now
there are a number of things that we can
take from this
and firstly the card looks like a
halloween card
captain obvious here now as the film is
based on the long halloween
it is possible that it is set during
this time
there was also a satellite picture which
showed several pumpkins dotted about an
area
which added further away to this theory
now if we jump ahead in the trailer
there is a press conference that can be
seen announcing the death of the mayor
you may notice the stairs in the
background and i've lined up the set
leaks with them
and they do look like they're the same
location confirming this is halloween
the owl on the front could also be a
reference to the court of owls
the big batman villains that pretty much
run gotham city
the court were introduced in the new 52
and if you don't know
they pretty much act as the illuminati
for the city controlling things from
behind the scenes
through their assassins the talons they
silence anyone that stands up to them
and they're definitely the ones to look
out for i actually have a theory that
the waynes
may have been members of the court and
that they were perhaps killed for this
typically we don't see them as corrupt
however in the last five years or so
both the film joker and the batman
telltale game have depicted them as
shady figures within the city
and it could be that they're tied to the
court i actually have a theory that the
riddler knew about this
and may have even suspected that their
son bruce had gone on to become a talon
perhaps he's confused batman is one of
their assassins
and this may also explain why the arm
gods that the character uses are very
similar to their armor
i can't see the film ending with bruce
finally defeating the riddler
and then he will reveal his mission
which was to stop the court
berlins are always far more complicated
when they're actually anti-heroes
and it is possible at the film's end
could reveal to batman
that he hasn't really stopped the big
bad that he thought and there's actually
a lot more going on
than he first suspected i would love to
see a court of owl's trilogy
and it would be incredible if the end of
the film revealed them all working away
behind the scenes
anyway the card is then opened to reveal
a coded message with symbols on it
once more this ties back to the zodiac
who used to send coded messages to the
press
announcing his killings now shout outs
to andrew lane for solving this riddle
and it actually says what does a liar do
when he's dead
with the answer being he lies still we
then go to the forensics team
taking photographs you can actually see
a headline that reads moroni drug bust
and in the comics moroni was actually
the character that created two-face
by throwing acid in harvey dent's face
during his trial
we do know that the da dies in this film
so it is possible that it opens the door
for den to come in and take over the
role
allowing for their fateful encounter to
happen if you've been keeping up to date
with our channel
and if not then why the hell not but if
you have then you may remember that we
reported on a character at the press
conference
here we can actually see that this was
moroni and side by side
the two look identical gordon then shows
the clue envelope with his signature
riddle of green on it
and batman steps forward we then cut to
commissioner pete savage
played by by trevor from eastenders look
i know that's not his real name but
i'll just i'll never forgive him for
what he did for little mo
she will have vengeance we continue at
the press conference
and can see what looks like the mayor's
widow to the right of savage
she is crying and she actually shows up
later in the trailer
at one key point when batman is pulling
the boy out of the way of the suv
we can also see her standing to the side
screaming and
as she's clearly trying to save the boy
herself this could mean
that he is in fact the son of the mayor
cut to batman peering over the crowd
and to the right we can also see a
number of news fans
you may remember that these were
actually shown in set leaks for the film
and it's nice to see them pop up back
here i love you
gotham hd now can you believe we're at
detail 48 already anyway i better get
moving now to the left we can also see
bruce removing his motorbike helmet
and this scene was too shown in the set
leaks you may also notice around his
mouth that he's wearing a covering
and this ties into the next shot of him
further looking over
what's going on you may also notice that
he's wearing
lovely lovely guy liner under the helmet
and
you know what as as much as this is
getting hate i actually
really like it typically in batman
movies we can see that his eyes
underneath the cowl have black around
them
however often when he removes it they
disappear so i'm glad that it's remained
here as
in my eyes adds a lot more authenticity
we then see the funeral scene itself
which is filmed at coddington sheds and
there are a number of notable things to
take from this
and firstly the suv looks like it has
doa written all over it
this obviously means dead on arrival
however
if you look closely at it it also has
the words d
a written on one of the windows doa is
of course a play on d
a the district attorney who in this film
is gil coulson
played by psalsgard if you look closely
you can actually see it's him
under the tape and yeah it doesn't look
like he he's gonna be hanging around for
long
there's also a riddler symbol on top of
the car and i just i just feel so bad
for
poor old gil now also is it just me or
whenever you hear the name
gil coulson do you think it's dc doing a
sly jab on phil coulson from marvel
probably just me but anyway so god has
hit it already that
his character is not going to be around
for very long and it is likely that
he knew his death was going to be in the
first trailer so i doubt warner brothers
had
any trouble with him spoiling it also
you can see his head coming off when he
explodes now
this is a reference to the real life
case of brian wells
which i can't go too far into because of
monetization on youtube
but if you watch the netflix documentary
evil genius
you'll find out a lot more about it
there and yeah
definitely check that out trust me trust
me now next we can see catwoman
sliding down a rope into a crime scene
this is obviously the mayor's office
from the start of the trailer
however if you need further confirmation
when she and batman fight one another we
can actually see the chair from the
beginning which the character is using
to lean against
catwoman is breaking into them as safe
and this is likely to get a ledger of
names
in the long halloween catwoman did this
too to falcone and batman confronted her
in his penthouse
it looks like this might actually be the
first time that the two meet and it's a
brilliant way to introduce her also
on the back of her head we can see that
her balaclava forms what looks to be cat
ears
we then go to the gotham docks namely
gotham sanitation
and see a mob meeting in mobster terms
sanitation is often referred to as the
cleaning up of bodies
and it looks like this could be the base
for penguin speaking of penguin
colin farrell looks absolutely
unrecognizable as the character
and i just have to say the prosthetic
work is incredible and i can't wait to
see his performance the character also
has a large scar under his face
showing that he himself has been through
a lot of battles
however as we know the penguin does use
a lot of goons to do his dirty work
now i have seen these mistakingly
labeled as the joker's gang
however in batman returns the penguin
two used clown-like villains
and in arkham city they also donned
black and white face paint
thus this is likely his forces and not
the jokers
later we see batman beat up one of these
thugs and the groups stand around
completely horrified
there's even this guy who who cries
what's the matter gonna cry now now i
actually think that this is setting up
the sons of batman
in the graphic novel the dark knight
returns there is a gang in gotham
that's called the mutants predominantly
this is made up of young teenagers
who've been influenced into a life of
crime by the mutant leader
however batman publicly beats the crap
out of him
in front of all his followers and they
decide to become a group known as the
sons of batman
who fight for justice in the city now on
top of this there were also a lot of
theories floating around that said this
movie was going to be set in the 90s
however we do see one of the gang
members holding up an iphone and film
filming his friend getting the absolute
crap being out of him
now we then see the batsuit in red
lighting and this is the same lighting
that was used in the initial batsuit
reveal
it is possible that this confirms one of
the leaks and actually shows the
destruction of the suit itself
in the funeral scene we can see that
batman gets blown backwards
by the explosion of gil coulson there's
also a little bomb disposal droid there
that you can see is
is it called a droid and look i don't
know anyway
this clearly damages the suit and we did
have a leaked post back in february that
pretty much detailed this scene
and said that because of it the batman
would have to make a new one
we then see batman beat up one of the
thugs in in the best five seconds ever
and when they ask who he is he says that
he's vengeance
this is actually a call back to the
graphic novel earth 1
in which the character introduces
himself in the exact same way
insiders contacted us a while back and
told us that the film would pull heavily
from the first two volumes of the run
you might remember that fans were an
uproar of a robber pattinson saying that
the batman was not a hero
however this quote was actually present
on the back of the book itself
which ties the two properties together
the phrase i'm vengeance is also a
reference to batman the animated series
in which he says i am vengeance i am the
knight
i am batman that was terrible now
as bad as that was i would love to see
this phrase peppered throughout the film
every time someone asks who he is with
the final answer being
i'm batman we then see the batmobile
burner on the back of the car
and it looks like the character is
chasing the penguin potentially after
his appearance at the docks
we do actually see the penguin firing at
a car and it looks like the one that
pulled up at the meeting at the
sanitation plan earlier
batman and catwoman then fight in the
mayor's office and i genuinely do think
that this is their first meeting
catwoman can later be seen riding on a
motorbike and this is likely
the same scene that we saw the stuntman
the stuntman fall over
who fell over how embarrassing now
there's also a very interesting moment
in which batman is grappling up some
stairs whilst clearly being fired at by
policemen
it's likely that this is a follow-on
from the scene in which we see batman
actually going to punch one hold him
back now i believe that batman is gonna
get framed by the riddler in the movie
and that this will escalate into the
police trying to hunt him down
batman has always had a very strained
relationship with the police
and on the whole he just tends to work
with gordon
perhaps this will all blow up and he'll
be forced to remain in the shadows
only meeting with gordon to discuss
police matters instead of being out in
the open
we then get some montages and you can
actually see the riddler's question mark
in the logo for the film
the ears on the a also form battiers and
this is a really nice touch in my
opinion
the trailer closes with batman in the
cave and this is where we hear
the riddler taunting him this ties back
to our wayne and the court of owls
theory
and i definitely think that it holds a
lot of weight here on a monitor we can
also see what looks like bella real
i think that this is possibly her
campaign ad in which she promises a
better gotham
we can also see the words gc on it so it
does look like
this may indeed be a news report either
it's announcing her
as a new mayor of gotham or perhaps the
riddler has even mocked her as a target
i really don't know yet but what an
incredible trailer
and thank you for watching the video now
that's our entire breakdown
and i hope you enjoyed it uh i'm sure
you can guess that
a ton of work went into this so if you
did then please share it
and maybe maybe put the caption as best
batman trailer breakdown ever
that way it'll trick people into
watching it the fools
now if you want something else to watch
then check out our breakdown of the
second batsuit leaks
which is going to be linked after this
we're also giving away a free copy of
the avengers on any console of your
choice
and all you have to do to begin with the
chance of winning is like the video
subscribe to the channel
and drop your thoughts below the winner
is going to be chosen at random on the
30th of august
so make sure you get involved if you
want to support the channel and get to
see content early
then please consider clicking the join
button below you can also come chat us
on the discord server
linked in the description or heavy
spoilers on twitter thanks for making it
until the end of the video
you've been the best i've been
definition i'll see you next time
take care peace
you